[Music]
Eddie you teach math every day not just
in the classroom let's have a look at
you in action on what you call your
rutube channel the sort of language
being familiar with have already said
okay take this guy and is really really
young lioness v and then and then take
this guy and turn around so that he sits
on like this because I'm on the way can
I just say probably every time something
meaningful is it what do I need to add
on in water to make this right so you
have 125 yes yes oh the reason I call is
part Indian country and in my very funny
completely swear I so wish I'd had
enough teacher like that it would have
been it would have been I may have had a
completely different career um your math
lesser those math lessons have clocked
up millions of views I think more than
three million right so what do you think
is the key to engaging with students we
heard quite a few times tonight I think
people think of mathematics is a very
abstract thing for me it's always been
about it's the struggle for a human
being to wrap their head around
something that's confusing at first and
requires a real change in perspective
but then all the one thing you sort of
heard that moment when the kids you know
and number two - that there's I mean
recognition yeah and when you can bring
people along with you mathematics people
think it's about numbers or it's about
shapes and they're there but they're
really about people trying to grapple
with this world around us and why is the
way it is and why why rainbows around
what's up with that
and a mathematician tried to work that
out and we know the reasons why and it's
beautiful
so for me connecting with people and
bringing them along in that journey is
just endlessly exciting we'll get you to
explain why rainbows around online
everyone but I'm really interested in
finding that out yet I'm Emily what did
you make mr. Wu when you first came
across him at school um well very
energetic but you could tell and I it's
easy to dismiss mass in the fact that
you don't understand why and always
someone who's you know that I asked why
things happen and you can go for English
you're encouraged to ask wide society
and culture you're encouraged but the
mass it's just there's a way of doing it
and that's the way it's done and you
would like the first math teacher to
ever explain why you do this like you
saw it and just make sense you hated
math oh yeah how much before you came a
cry I wanted to drop it because at the
end of your ten you can drop math and
with that because you'd had teachers
that hadn't engaged you in it yeah I
because I never thought I had the brain
for math it just never made sense to me
so I get frustrated at it lots of
teachers would get frustrated because I
would get frustrated and and Eddie how
did you convince her to keep going with
math I think it's easier than people
think because really I think it's adds
with anything but people get frustrated
when if you play a game and you're just
losing all the time that's no fun and I
have little kids the three six and eight
and if they just constantly never
winning at a game they'll just with the
table and fork off but I think if you
can get any child to that moment where
they realize oh oh is that all this is I
I can get how that works I can see why
these pieces fit together then it's sort
of your eyes begin to open a little more
to this is something worth spending time
on hmm Emily why did you keep going with
math what was the motivation once you
got engaged um I think Keith's codes
motivation sorry third embarrasses um
Andy he realizes how much he kind of
changed my mind on this I want to make
him feel like I was an achievement I
want to do better for him because I know
he is faith in me and and so I get
really frustrated at everyone else in my
class we're not listening
stand how much you're doing for us and
it's just it feels like he's making
connection to us and all the teachers
don't it's nice how you going at maths
now I think I'm doing better
I want to do better I'm driving she's
doing a lot better